so uh
we see that in the hierarchy of
biological classification this is what
we will be called
microbial community that we
different tissues as a
studied organ is the gut but gut is not
the only place where these communities
live with and specific microbiomes
actually
co-exist with us or with the hosts and
they're all vital for our health and
they are found in
skin in in
red parts and also too sometimes
recent studies are
called two bias
and
insights as we already discussed uh into
the way these communities function and
how their composition right generally
their composition in terms of or in the
function of their abundance level are
linked to the host condition that we are
studying so what are the host conditions
that we can relate this to for example
in the human microbiome project we have
several of the parameters so several of
the
data
that we can associate these adult
microbiome and their um
their composition too they can be
they can be linked to the bmi they can
be linked to their lifestyle they can be
linked to dietary habits they can be
linked to smoking and drinking habits
they can be linked to exercise frequency
and several of these characteristics can
be
can be explored right and
while exploring this when we form
two subsets of these samples based on
uh based on the
lifestyle or based on the
health index or based on these
these characteristics we can actually
relate or we can actually identify a
balanced microbiota which is referred to
as biosis and
and symbiosis and also we can also
characterize
the level of unbalanced microbiota
which is referred to as dysbiosis in the
event of
microbial population that are found in
patients are found in people with
chronic diseases or people that are
related to disease conditions in general
right in addition to this we can also
have several
types of
these microbiome that are characterized
for their ability to help us maintain a
good biosis or symbiosis right this can
be
used in terms of
foliage new probiotic
samples and
yeah
and etc
so we have why a while uh when we are
performing this analysis we can actually
identify and we can actually list uh for
example uh
bacteria types such as bacterial phyla
such as bacterial identities
proteobacteria and
their involvement in maintaining the
symbiosis
thermocute is usually
associated with
with the increased level
so
these are all several several different
associations that we can perform so
basically in summary what we want to do
is we want to have a microbial
quantification for the samples under at
least two different conditions right one
condition could be
from unhealthy state of this organism
and the other condition could be healthy
state or time control or tax
this doesn't have to stop at exploring
the health issues of human this can
extend to for example
for example the suitability of the soil
samples for plant growth this can
this can extend to uh for example um
soil uh
quantification characterization in
general right and and several
applications of this is actually done
and uh yeah etcetera that can be studied
so we will take a look at couple of
these practical examples and in these
practical examples i want to show you
some of the i want to highlight some of
the important
key findings and how we can perform some
of the analysis using omics logic
portal to arrive at this conclusion and
how we can leverage publicly available
resources to generate a hypothesis on
how that hypothesis can be tested using
code free environment in trying to
analyze the microbial or meta genomics
data and also using some code oriented
downstream analysis that are focusing on
understanding the diversity of this
microbial population
right
so if you have any questions until now
this is the time that you want to uh
ask and you can i'm monitoring the chat
as i mentioned please go ahead and ask
me the questions and before we jump into
the practical examples
okay
thank you sugar
so um
so we already spoke about human
microbial american microbeam project and
we we have uh for example
uh american gut project which can be
used to find patterns in the guts right
patterns in the microbial population
that can
be used to study different ages in
different population or that can
generally be used to
link to uh where these
populations are microbes are actually
sourced from and that can also be linked
to several other comparison like
like the abundance level of specific uh
specific microbial population and etc
etc in general this is the data that we
have from this publicly available
resources so you can it can we can
leverage the
gut sample and we can leverage several
samples and their
abundance levels of these
microbes and they can these abundance
levels can be related to as i already
mentioned um
for those people under different
clinical conditions like those who
exercise regularly and those who
exercise badly so in addition to this we
have several of these clinical
parameters and clinical conditions to
relate that to and you're all free to
check that
check and this
american gut
database and that is this
mymicrobiome.info
website so in addition to this we can
also focus on the um
skin microbiome which is established
in this study which are identified uh to
play a key role in maintaining the
healthiness and maintaining the
symbiosis in
in the skin condition and also dysbiosis
in this skin microbiome and their
signaling is actually directly related
to several
acute skin diseases like
eczema and other rashes etc etc so you
can also check this out these are all
very important
publications that you want to explore in
order to understand the use and not
understand the applications of this
microbiome and metagenomics
data analysis so
the next in focus would be
the effect of these antibiotics in red
syndrome and for this i want to
extend the sharing of my screen to ah
exploring this project from omixlogic
platform and we will understand how
studying the microbial dysbiosis in the
redstone will help us
generally relate
these dysfunctional abundance to one of
the rare neurological disorders that are
affecting the
affecting children
so let me reshare my screen
with my browser
okay
just
let me know if you can see my screen
yes sir it's visible yes
thank you very much so uh
so it is this is an example project that
actually focuses on uh understanding the
microbial yeah thank you very much right
for the link and those who have access
to this project can actually open up
this project with your
login credentials and explore it with me
or you can also do this late so
we focus on
the lessons that generally starts
with the focus on
[Music]
relating the effectiveness of the drugs
against these different microbial
population and their effect of effect on
on
disturbing the balance of this microbial
population in general and these drugs
for example are actually non-antibiotic
drugs and their effect on microbiota
[Music]
what are the key understanding of these
ones so in
in a nutshell what this actually does is
we actually identify some of the key
bacterial population
and
and their involvement in maintaining
uh symbiosis and and how they are
actually depleted in terms of uh while
while using several of these uh
non-antibiotic restricted drugs that we
use and
you can go through this lesson to get to
the specifics but more than 70
percentage of the drugs will have one or
the other will affect one or the other
population of these
useful or
helpful microbial communities and this
actually lists out some of the
helpful microbial community that are uh
that are related to maintaining good
health like uh beauty rate produces like
propionate producers like
anterotypes and etc so we take this
information and then we go back to
another publication
that generally understands the or
generally focuses on
characterizing the abundance of
microbial community in in gut and relate
that to red syndrome either syndrome is
a extremely rare neurological or a
neurodevelopmental disorder that
affects
mainly kids or children so
we want to understand whether do we have
any relationships or
whether we can
test the hypothesis does that
from the previous publication or from
the previous relationship that these
beneficial microbial communities are the
ones that are among
the microbes that are mostly affected in
the
in the event of red syndrome samples
that we want to find out that's a
hypothesis that we are testing in this
specific
example project so next you can check
some of the
examples or some of the
[Music]
associated research and the
whistles on
what was generally done in this
publication and
how we are going to use this data to
study or to test our hypothesis
and one of them is going to get this
load one of them is going to be
uh using the processed data of the
tabulated data
and setting up a data to pipeline in the
t bio info server so this data to
pipeline will actually
give us a lot of output that we can take
this output and use this uh output
either in
in
the visualization that we get from the
tbio info server and then the
interactive
environment that we get in the tbio info
server and understand or we can also use
kind analysis so
on top of this data to analysis and
packages everything into a time object
or kind uh compressed
data type and this kind compressed data
type can be downloaded and they can be
straight away visualized into kind
visualizer that you can access online
in uh in the kind database or in the
time uh website so first let us
see how we can set up these data sets
and how we can set up this data analysis
and this lesson actually focuses on
where this data comes from and what do
we need to do to get these short read
sequencing
data and to
use these short sequencing data to uh
to arrive at the taxonomic table and
etcetera etcetera so that is
what this one focuses on first primarily
uh in this
in in these steps to download data and
once you have obtained at this table we
can actually perform this uh downstream
analysis of this um using data to
pipeline and we can set up these
analysis in in the
server also
and
this and our
part of this data or curated part of
portion of this data is included as a
demo pipeline in the server p bioinfo
server let this complete loading and it
can be accessed under this uh amplicon
16s or 18 sequencing in the metagenomics
section so if you have login credentials
to server tibor info server irrespective
of your subscription pattern or
subscription model you can access all of
the demo pipelines and this demo
pipeline can be accessed by these using
these drop down
button or clicking option and in this we
can see uh
i think it's in the red syndrome is
here yeah that's information time but um
i will i will generally show you how to
set up a data to pipeline
not for the red syndrome but for the
different projects
so we start with the analysis part and
the input files are actually
already uploaded and we have you can
access them from here and once you start
we actually perform some quality control
for our
files
and then we
count them or use the
data to uh processes to count to merge
and to cluster these
ots that's what we will do and once this
has been done we can actually remove
more than one otu uh cluster dash or
whether one type of otus trusted into
one cluster there are chimeras and we
can then use these oto sequences to
explore the silva database or any other
database to assign tax
then we can use a
[Music]
neighbor joining algorithm to develop
phylogenetics of these proteus which is
one of the key
steps in understanding or in
exploring or characterizing the
diversity of these otus or these samples
then we can perform data visualization
then we can end the pipeline so once you
build this pipeline for the analysis and
in any method data to account to you
will get access to all the output files
that you can download and you can
visualize and we can explore and what to
explore and what to perform and what are
the analysis to focus on what are the
results to be
identified and implicated can be
thoroughly
read and understood from the associated
resources that we are linking to
during each and every session of the
program
so i want to show you some of the uh
visualization that we actually show
and this is the abundance plot
that you will
often
see or often notice in microbial or
metagenomics related publication
i think we should be yes exactly yeah
and we this is an interactive abundance
part we can quickly check which
tax of bacteria is this does this
specific section
and we see some
difference in the abundance level of
these bacterial identities for different
samples that can be related to their
biological condition or phenotypic
and this uh specific plot which is not
proportional plot which is raw abundance
plot and the relative abundance ah
relative proportional abundance plot can
be used to understand
the proportional abundance of several
different microbial population
or different samples
so this project also i think gives you
option two um
guys to run the pipeline i think in the
yes it gives the same result same
discusses the same thing here
here is where you can actually uh
access the pipeline that we are
we actually set up for the
lesson the b focuses on focus on right
it's the same uh data to pipeline but
for the uh
it's not for the reds don't know it's
first different pipelines okay
so uh i wanted to
show you that this proportional plot
will help us ah
clear some of the hypothesis that we
generally
develop once seeing the non-proportional
or absolute
abundance plot now if we see this level
of the bacterial identities in these
three samples they are absolutely
identical ah because it has been scaled
up or it has been normalized across the
difference happens that's what i wanted
to show you so these
interactive visualization will help
abundance level of our abundance level
of microbial community from our sample
and in order to perform more uh specific
analysis that we will also uh briefly
and
then we don't like r or python 2 do the
perform that analysis go to the server
and that can be accessed again as a demo
pipeline under the chime section of the
meta genomics
part right in this
kind we see that the red syndrome
project is here
we can go and set up this analysis
quickly
so crime adds some more uh
steps to process and preprocess the data
and post process the data into time
objects
before applying data to pipeline into
that or data to analysis into that into
our data
right
and it does it performs all the steps
that we do in the data too
but it gives us some more options or
more options to
perform some quality visualization
once this is done
the details for these steps are all
included in the associated publications
uh not publication in the associated
resources
go
so when you sign up for this program you
will get access to
okay what happened here
can you see my screen it's little bit
yes sir the screen is visible just it's
black
blacked out right yeah for some reasons
it is yeah for some reason
okay let me start over again
in order to access the
dashboard or
analyzing this data or changing the
key parameters of this data
during visualization process
so that you can perform this analysis
without
rerunning the pipeline or without any
without resorting to any code based
methods which we will also explore
option is available for kind
and
for most of the pipelines that you are
going to set up in the talbot bioinfo
server
so the process involves in
selecting the next available or
choosing
uh one of the next available
analysis options that are highlighted
when you select the previous ones so
since this is a demo pipeline it's it's
only letting me select uh the path with
which we have set up the pipeline and in
reality when you select or when you opt
for this analysis methods when you
select one of these
options or algorithms then it's going to
give you all the or it's going to
highlight all possible route that you
can take so why should i say that you
can design your analysis
methods or sequences depending upon the
data depending upon the ah hypothesis
that you are actually testing so this
external dashboard will give you options
like
dated load
options like changing the taxonomic
level of your relative abundance plot
right so in the interactive
visualization plot the taxonomic level
is fixed once we have uh when we are
running the pipeline or when we are
accessing the pipeline setting up the
pipeline here you can change that from
the family level you can change that to
phylum
level
and
explore their informative
level of informativeness right
look at this the phylum level is not
very informative because it is most of
them are actually populated by
firmicutes and uh
the best level at which we can study
this is at the genus or family level
genus could be too varied
and it can have several of the
not applicable
or unknown resources
in them for example unknown or
uncultured organisms or other organisms
here as grouped by these purple cases
right they are all other which are
unclassified a genus so
one level
related to
red syndrome or not from the disease
that is the host disease
yes here and then it is going to update
by itself
and then you can export for them for
their
separation for their
distribution so again in the diversity
plot
you can check
different categories of different uh
annotations of your of your samples here
i'm focused i am focused on red syndrome
you can also change this up by selecting
for example body mouse index body mass
index etcetera etcetera that we want to
select so uh this dashboard gives you uh
freedom and flexibility to change the
annotation to change the grouping level
and to change the
display of the of the associated plots
that uh
that are not possible in the uh
in the interactive platform or that that
are very helpful when you are opting for
when when we want to understand uh
metagenomics data analysis using a code
free
option
and this can also be performed using r
as a
tool for analysis and that is actually
given in the in this project 13 which is
which explores the role of high fat diet
on obesity using model system like mouse
right and when we go back to my uh
keynote let's see
can you see my screen
so it's loading it's not visible yet
yes
yes and now it's good yeah right the
user helpful uh the
the advantage of using a model system to
understand microbial the effect of
microbial community and their abundance
level on several different
aspects is actually that we can use
specific antibiotics to completely
reduce or completely nullify the
existing bacterial load in the model
system which is not possible for human
samples so we can take a mouse model for
example and then completely devoid that
most model for for any
trace of microbial community in their
gut and then load them up with a
specific
we can
process at the end of
observation process and quantify their
abundance level that is what is actually
done in this specific project so they
take the mouse samples and for
completely cleaned up mouse they give
the mouse um
microbial community that is developed
that is built or that is actually uh
developed for different mouse that takes
hypha diet and for another mouse
microbial
samples from multiple samples from
another mouse that take normal diet
so and the behavioral changes for mouse
that received microbial transplantation
community transplantation from high fat
diet fed mouse and
compared it to the microbial
transplantation now transplanted mouse
that received
transportation from a normal diet mouse
and their behavior this um
differences are actually studied after
given number of time on the top actually
explored in this specific
project so
on
this downstream analysis which takes the
tables or which takes
the abundance table which takes the
taxonomic table under which also takes a
sample
sample annotation and then we can
perform downstream analysis using r and
using a package that we will definitely
explore during the program that
[Music]
and their usage in using filo seek
packets right in this final sig package
we can we can bundle up this abundance
table and this
this taxonomic information and this
annotation information into one object
and this one object is what has been
repeatedly being used to study for
example
to measure the diversity across
different sample or across groups of
samples in terms of alpha diversity or
in terms of beta diversity that can also
be
studied
right yeah this is
this is simply
the nmds plot to show their differences
uh using bray distance method and some
more uh phylogeny based distance methods
like unifrac and these ones are also
explored and given
detailed account of how to perform this
analysis using r as a tool for
performing this analysis this gives you
lot of flexibility in terms of the
number of samples to analyze in terms of
what are the distance methods that you
can choose to
analyze and
visualization options like pcoa nmds or
umap to use to visualize your samples so
and it also gives you a lot of freedom
in in terms of grouping of samples
according to phyla kingdom and etc or
you can also for example
restrict your analysis to top 25 otus
top 50 depending upon their abundance
levels or depending upon their diversity
levels in this case so that can also be
studied so this
rsa tool for downstream analysis gives
you all the codes for performing this
analysis and it also gives you a portion
where you can try your knowledge of
performing this analysis from the
previous two resources right it gives
you or this console is a
is an r console that is loaded at the
back end and we can perform all the
analysis
given in these measures of diversity are
given in these sections
i use these to perform the analysis and
we have given you small
assignments and challenges then these
challenges can be accessed from lesson
six this is a continuation of lesson six
so we go back to lesson six quickly
which focuses on how to set up this
downstream analysis in pyelosic and
development
down down
yes in try it yourself section
so we give options or we give links to
the input table and then we actually
leave out some of the key portions of
the syntax for example here this is left
out free or left out incomplete so that
you can refer or you can base on your
understanding of how this is performed
complete this analysis in this console
and gain
good feedback about for your own
understanding uh
for this uh code based lessons so uh
similar analysis is also perform is also
um
possible in python and more details are
actually available in
other associated resources and also in
we will explore python's option to
perform this analysis in the program
also